à vos marques prêts composter
inauguration du premier restaurant
universitaire écolo de France sur le
campus des sciences à Versailles à la
fin de leur repas les 700 étudiants et
personnels trient désormais le reste de
nourriture dans des bacs spécifiques des
bacs vidés quotidiennement pour
alimenter les containers à compostage
derrière le restaurant Les États-Unis
pour accélérer la fermentation les
résidus alimentaires sont recouverts de
déchets verts fournis par le service
technique de la ville comme le bois issu
de l'élagage et les tentes de gazon donc
ça c'est le bac qui sert justement à
récupérer toute cette tout ce broyat et
tous ces déchets verts et puis vous avez
dans celui-là c'est le bac principal
dans lequel chaque jour au quotidien les
agents techniques du site apportent les
déchets alimentaires
qu'il recouvre de des broyas qui sont
juste à côté les biodéchets transformés
en compost après fermentation serviront
d'engrais naturel pour les espaces verts
du campus scientifique et pour les
massifs arbustifs et fleuris de
Versailles avec 22000 euros de budget
financé par l'ADEME le CROUS la région
et la fondation partenariale fondatera
ce projet pilote décoru en temps donné
l'exemple la question de déploiement du
tri et du compostage c'est effectivement
on le voit bien une démarche collective
donc
nécessité finalement d'aller un petit
peu plus loin dans
l'écosystème sur le territoire et être
capable de mettre en place ce type de
projet
chaque année 10 tonnes de déchets
alimentaires sont produites par les 137
000 repas servis à lui à faire science
de Versailles